I thought today maybe we would talk
about grant a well-known command in the
UNIX world something that's been around
since the early 1970s
what grep lets you do is to search for
patterns of text arbitrary patterns of
text in one or more files and there
could be an unbounded number of files of
input or the input could be coming from
some other program for example as it is
in if you're using unix pipeline so you
take some program and you pipe it into
grep and that way no matter what the
amount of input is grep can filter out
or show you the things that you're
interested in and that's stuff that you
can't do with the text editor very
conveniently if at all one of the issues
with grep has always been where does
that weird name come from and so I
thought perhaps I could tell that story
that would be of any interest and we'll
see where we go from there the way it
came about you have to put yourself back
in the early days of computing before
everybody present in this room except me
was born let's say something like 1970
71 Sun the very very early days of UNIX
the computer that UNIX ran on was a PDP
11 at that point it was probably 11 20
was a machine that had very very little
computing power it didn't run very fast
it also didn't have very much memory
probably something in the order of 32 K
maybe 64 K bytes and a 64 K bytes not
megabytes and very small secondary
storage as well you know a few megabytes
of disk and things like that
so very very limited computing resources
and that meant that a lot of the
software that was in early days of UNIX
tended to be fairly simple and
straightforward and that reflected not
only the sort of the relative wimpiness
of the hardware but also the personal
tastes of the people doing the work
primarily Ken Thompson and Dennis
Ritchie so one of the prop one of the
standard programs that people use is the
text editor on any system the UNIX text
editor was called edy and it's not
pronounced ad at least by those in the
know it's pronounced edy um and this was
written by Ken Thompson and I think it
was a basically stripped-down version of
an
are called QED which Ken had worked with
and done a lot of work on earlier so
very small simple straightforward editor
and the thing that you have to remember
is that in those days in addition you
didn't have actual video display
terminals not that of the sort that
we're used to today or even 10 or 20
years ago but in fact all the computing
all of your editing in zone was done on
paper
remember paper if you zoom down here you
can see paper this meant that there were
a lot of things that tried to minimize
the use of paper it also meant that
editors worked one line at a time were
multiple lines at a time but there was
no cursor addressing so you couldn't
move around within a line and so the IDI
text editor reflected that kind of thing
maybe what I should do is just a quick
look at what IDI looked like so the
commands for IDI where single letter
commands so for example there was a
command called P which stood for print
there was a command called digue which
would delete a line there was a command
called s which took a little bit which
said substitute so you could change this
you know ABC into D EF or something like
that there was an append command that
simply said add some more text and you
could add a bunch of lines and then
terminate it with something there was of
course a read command so that you could
read information from a file and there
was a write command that you could put
it back in a file a handful of other
things like that so that was the essence
of what it did one of the things that
IDI did very nicely was then okd
supplied by default to the current line
but what do you do when you want to have
more specification of what lines you're
operating on and so you could say things
like line 1 to line 10 print so this
would print the first two 10 lines 10
was that but suppose you wanted to print
all of the lines in the file so there
was a shorthand called dollar so I could
say 1 comma dollar P and that would
print all of the lines in the file or I
could say gee I wonder I just want to
see the last line so I could say dollar
P and that would give me that I could
even elide the P but that's good enough
or I could delete the last line by
saying dollar D or I could delete the
first line by saying 1 D that is sort of
the line addressing
so far not very complicated the thing
that edy added to all of that and this
is definitely Ken's influence was the
idea of regular expressions so regular
expression is a pattern of text two ways
specifying patterns of Teck they could
be literal texts like the word print or
they could be something more complicated
like things that start with PRI and but
might go on to print or Princeton or
princess or whatever that kind of thing
and the way that regular expressions
were written in the IDI text editor was
you said slash and then you wrote the
characters of the regular expression so
I could say slash print and that would
be something that would match the next
line in what I was working on that
contained the word print anywhere within
it so the regular expressions in the IDI
editor were somewhat different a little
more sophisticated and complicated than
the regular expressions that you might
find in shell wildcards where for
example a star means anything at all so
the same idea of patterns of text a
slightly different specification
different way of writing patterns but
suitable for text editing and so then I
could say things like I want to find the
next occurrence of the word print in my
file and then there I would be and on
and on and on like that okay so that's
the Edie text editor we were a long way
away from grep at this point so what's a
grep of all about well it turns out that
at the time that this was going on Edie
was the standard text editor but as I
said the machines you're working on a
very very wimpy
not much computing capacity in a lot of
ways and in fact one of the limitations
was that you couldn't edit a very big
file because there wasn't enough memory
and the IDI worked entirely within
memory and so you were stuck one of my
colleagues at the time Lee McMahon was
very interested in doing text analysis
of the sort of thing that we would call
today perhaps natural language
processing and so what Lee wanted to do
he had been studying something that with
the time was very interested in the
question of who were the authors of some
fundamental American documents called
the Federalist Papers The Federalist
Papers were written by variously James
Madison and Alexander Hamilton and John
J in 1780
seven and eighty-eight if I recall
correctly there were 85 of these
documents but they were published
anonymously under the name Publius and
so we had no idea in theory who wrote
them and so there's been a lot of
scholarship trying to figure out for
sure it's well known who wrote some of
them and others are still I think a
little uncertain and so Lee was
interested in and seeing whether you
could actually by textual analysis of
his own devising figure out who wrote
these things so that's fine
but it turns out that these 85 documents
was total just over a megabyte I mean
down in the noise by today's standards
wouldn't fit he couldn't edit them all
EDD and so what do you do so one day he
said I just want to go through and find
all the occurrences of something in in
the Federalist Papers so I could look at
him and he said this to Ken Thompson and
and then went home for dinner or
something like that and he came back the
next day and Ken had written the program
the program was called CREP
and what grep did was to go through a
bunch of documents one or more files and
simply find all of the places where a
particular regular expression appeared
in those things and so the way it turns
out that one more of the commands in
didi is a command called G and that this
stood for global and what it said was on
every line that matches a particular
regular expression so for example grant
I can then do an e D command so I could
say on every line that contains the word
print I'll just print it so I can see
what my various print statements would
look like or I could in some other way
say G and some other regular expression
in there and delete them so I could
delete all of the comments in a program
or something like that so the general
structure of that is G followed by in
slashes a regular expression followed by
the letter P grabbed and that's the
genesis of where it came from
okay and so this is in some ways the
genius of ken Thompson a beautiful
program written in no time at all by
taking some other program and just
trimming it out and then giving it a
name that stuck that's the story a where
grep came from
one thing 25 years ago literally was the
spring of 1993 I was teaching at
Princeton as a visitor and I needed an
assignment for my programming class and
I thought hmm so what I did was to tell
them the students in the class okay here
is the source code for Edie it was at
that time probably eighteen hundred
lines of see your job is to take these
eighteen eighteen hundred lines of C and
convert them into grep as a C program
okay and you've got a week to do it and
I told them at that point that they had
a couple of advantages first they knew
what the target was somebody had already
done grep so they knew what it was
supposed to look like and all they had
to do is replicate that behavior and the
other thing is that it was now written
in C the original grep was written in
PDP love an assembly language and of
course they also had one grave
disadvantage and none of them were Ken
Thompson the next engine cable and you
can see quite a lot of that going on in
the back there looks a bit of a mess but
it is functional and of course it can
get a bit farther apart you can put a
lot more air through
keep the heat down